and and then we'll have some fun but
good luck guys you good afternoon
everyone and thank you for joining us
this afternoon and this is the third
live podcast webinar so really I'm
excited for this one and joined by some
great panelists and it's the first time
it's gonna it's an all Manchester plan
which is interesting all we just crack
on and with the introductions and stuff
I just very quickly I just I just jot
down some names on people I just want to
give a bit of a shout out to because
they've they've been on every single
podcast webinar so far so I just really
appreciate the support so just wanted to
give a very very quick shout out to Mike
Richards Nathan Adams Lily ship and
Hannah Foley Lauren Lang staff Robert
and Robert Hana so thank you for your
support really appreciate it and let's
have some fun so Louise if you could go
further if you could intro yourself for
everyone watching and tuning them my
name is Louise Davey and I am the MD of
white label recruitment and we're based
in Manchester at the moment we've got 19
staff and we could be the engineering
market on a permanent contract basis
amazing Thank You Louise John yeah I'm
John Gordon I'm the CEO of Finley James
we're a global tech sales recruitment
company we've got circa 47 48 people and
they're based in Manchester had office
London San Francisco and New York
amazing thank you John last but not
least yeah my name's Sean McCleary i'm
md of insight recruitment we write in
engineering recruitment based in
Manchester we've got fourteen people
currently yeah cool Thank You Sean so
just a bit of housekeeping and everyone
that is tuning in so you should be able
to see to the right or left of us and a
Q&A section
so I'm just
type in here to art your names here so
you should all be able to see the the
question that I sent and at any time you
can submit your questions a big part of
today is very much going to be and you
guys asking questions and making sure
the panel answer them so what you also
be able to do is if you see someone
submit a question that you really like
you'll be able to click up vote and that
will just meet that that's a question
that you'd really like them to answer so
at any point you want to ask Sean John
Louise a question make sure you type it
in then I'll make sure it gets answered
so look guys I've got a couple of
questions before we start getting some
questions from the audience
and but I've got to start with this one
it was sent in from Michael from sw6 and
the first question I've got is are
northerners better than southerners to
ask that where I'd like to start is a
lot of you guys have been in the
recruiting industry for a while and
definitely around when and the adversity
that a lot of people had to go through
in the past so the saw the first
question I have is what what have you
guys learned from previous times of
adversity challenges you had to overcome
that you think holds true in today's
current landscape and the current
challenges that we're all facing what
comes up for you guys when I ask that
okay so my thoughts are I think going
back to 2008 2009 we went went through
that last recession we were we're a much
smaller company we're a 20-person
company but we quickly realized that
kind of doing nothing and waiting for
the market to change wasn't an option
okay so myself and my business partner
mark at that time you know we quickly
decided that we weren't gonna take any
money for a period of time well and you
know we sat down with the
team and we basically said look this is
this is pretty horrific you know we went
from we were quite small we were turning
over all perm we went from doing 100 a
month to 220 a month yeah for you know
two or three months so it was it was a
big drop-off so we at that point weren't
taking any money and we asked the people
within the team to take a pay cut a
reduction yeah
[Applause]
no no government not sure whether I
think the government were hiding behind
the bankers at this point but yeah there
was no how there was no assistance it
was everybody was you know on their own
and also there was no help at all from
you know networking groups you know
people I could see are n people like the
hive yeah to basically talk to people in
the same boat to get advice so I think
what we learn and what we did was you
know act and act fast to make changes
and stop living in the past you know you
need to start living in the present and
the future and make some tough decisions
and some pretty important decisions but
at that time we made one person
redundant one person I decided to leave
the business you know they didn't want
to take the pay cut but everybody else
stayed with me even now our RMD now
James May we have been with me for you
know over 12 years he was one of those
guys as an entry-level recruiter who
took part in that and came out the other
side and he's progressed right through
the companies to be our managing
director so I think the advice is did do
something and not yeah don't stick your
head in the sand hoping for it sir to be
better tomorrow
anything else her ad Louise I've gone
yeah I think that's that's a really good
point about not not living in the past
and there's been a couple of times where
we've had a few a few things happen at
my label where we've got to make some
big changes and if you keep looking
backwards and saying that's what week
that's what we do that's what we usually
do you do not you're not going in the
right direction
I think as long as you team are on board
with making some big changes for the
short-term yeah you should you should be
okay but if you've got people in the
team saying I'm not willing to do that
and this isn't what my job is this is
what I'm paid today
and they're not willing to be flexible I
think you got enough problem so I think
subtly now quite early on mmm okay you
say is important if you think that's
gonna happen
sure yeah I'd agree with both points I
think John's point around making
decisions and making them fast I think I
think that's key you know whatever it is
that you you know you're going to decide
to do I think acting and giving people
confidence that you are proactively
doing something is important I'd also
say you know don't forget about the
customer or most most importantly some
of the best relationships if I think
bats of 2008 and you know would would be
made then with customers where you can
still add value when you know every
other recruit is probably not calling
them or not wanting to speak to them
because you know they don't want to have
that difficult conversation so you know
you don't necessarily need to call them
about jobs for example or you know being
there to say look we're all in this
together work and we are value to you
right now yeah I think we'll come back
with engagement when the market does
inevitably pick up okay so on that then
making decisions thinking about the
present and communicating to your team
clients etc what so right now in the
present what what's been them the most
difficult decision that you guys have
had to make so far yeah I start off I
think I think pretty much every business
I would say at the moment is looking at
cash flow pipeline looking at okay well
you know how we have we got the
resources to be able to continue at the
level that we want to continue out which
certainly from an insight point of view
we've done yeah and I think it's been
difficult in the respect of you know you
I make decisions on people with
different levels of experience different
markets and you're trying to you know
you're trying to put some kind of a
formula to say okay well how can I get
this business through this difficult
time but measure that we're in a
position to still be successful when the
inevitable upturn comes yeah so so we
decided from an insight point of view to
very much have a collective we're all in
it together approach to it with everyone
committing to take a court in terms of
hours and and I think you know I've got
to say hats off to to everyone that's
been involved from my staff that that
family approach to it as men has made
that decision a lot easier than it could
have been okay yeah Louis John most
difficult decision you've had to make so
far at the last couple of weeks so it
would be discussing the furlough I'm
putting the option in and now which side
from today yeah
it was quite hard for kids I think we've
got all these networking groups that
women that were linked into which is
brilliant but Paula spent a long time
speaking to different people and not to
making a decision quite hard and
thinking about what some of what's other
companies doing assistive ID types and
not actually sucking yourself and going
actually this is why I think's right and
actually making that decision I think I
said that to yesterday
yeah feels so much better just making up
making that decision and but yeah it was
really really tough and thinking you
know how the staff gonna react to me how
I gonna we're gonna come out of this but
today actually feels like a big weights
been we've been lifted and we can
actually move forward with the business
now I'm actually progress and because
I've got a plan so I think just not
making a decision it's obviously it's
back to John John's point they're like
back in 2008 where there wasn't loads of
help that you can see d'etre but this
sort of downfall of having a lot of help
and support in there you can always look
and to get the answer from other people
and yeah then you can make your own
decision and John what about you then
also know we had an open conversation
yesterday but as it is it sort of in
line with Louise on difficult decisions
around furloughing and how to help the
laughs and what what's been difficult
for you yeah I think the following is
definitely right up there and I think in
some respects that decision was made a
little bit easier so that we had started
to kind of consider the furloughing
conversation and you know we would think
about you know looking at matrix looking
at our list you know who can contribute
and perform under these conditions and
stay on the pitch and who are going to
be better served you know on the bench
you know ready to come back contributing
down the line and I think one of the
things that's great from you know
talking's people is that you know we
were advised to instead of going to
people and saying look you're on the
list
you're being furloughed it was who
within the business would be comfortable
and happy to be furloughed okay based on
kind of our understanding in our
appreciation of what the world is going
to look like and we've done it from a
protective perspective whereby we've
said look you know being in this market
at this moment in time is a bit like
walking into a burning building now yeah
if you're gonna walk into a burning
building and you've got the experience
the apparatus the know-how the skill to
navigate your way through over the next
two months that's brilliant
you know be on the pitch if you haven't
you can help us in another way and help
our bottom line while the guys who were
not further just hoping the top line so
what I've actually says what was gonna
be a really really hard decision it all
kind of opened up in front of us as as
not being a difficult decision at all
because it was people chose and it was
down to them whether they wanted to
remain on the pitch yeah or go to
fellows so we haven't got anybody on
furlough today out of 19 people
including Sarah my wife and business
partner who weren't happy and
comfortable making that call okay well
thanks for sharing that so no I think a
lot of questions got submitted by people
around the furlough piece nil-nil Clough
is already asked one and I think it's a
interesting one so let's go to that
question what what are you guys doing
then to get keep with staff motivate and
sort of that constant contact with them
because yeah the people that you have
put on furlough what what the sort of
four processes and how are you planning
on keeping the staff motivated and
engaged whilst on furlough I can tell
you what we're doing so basically saara
as the head of the furloughs you know
she's already created a new cycle yeah I
could run and run they've also they've
already sorted out a playlist you know
furlough playlist but a furlough
playlist so well some some interesting
contenders are already so yeah we've got
you know 19 people and the idea is that
we're going to have you know Sawa's
going to be running some sessions with
them in terms of you know having a
catch-up on a weekly basis to check in
make sure everybody's okay they've got a
whatsapp group to communicate on all
non-work-related stuff I'm going to give
everybody an update in terms of the like
the temperature of the business you know
how we'd got on how things have done the
good the bad the ugly so people are
still connected to the business and
understand what's going on even though
they can't contribute and they can't be
selling within the business so the idea
is we want those 19 people including
Sarah to be you know on the sub Spanish
but keeping fit and you know being
warmed up ready to be called on when we
come out the other side of this and we
may well find that people who are
cracking on and you know selling today
and placing people today they may well
need a breather in a month or twos time
and they'll need people ready to perform
so I think having two distinct groups
but we're still part of the the FGA
family we're just helping the business
in two different ways you know one on
the top line one on the bottom line
really it's all about communication a
number of the guys are going to be
in the NHS for the facility yes saurus
one of the guys doing that natalie is
another so a bunch of them will be you
know helping the community and helping
you know parents elderly parents
grandparents and still contributing to
society in example if you complain
amazing yeah
so your yeah so you're really doubling
down on the communication with with the
people that you have furloughed one with
a weekly group video called whatsapp
groups are as dedicated to communicating
to these guys okay cool
Louie's Sean what what are you making
sure you do to the people that you
fellow to make sure that yeah you
keeping them engaged and what the plans
on communication and if indifferent to
that or oh really similar and the only
other thing that I'm just still waiting
on and the classification around
training I kind of just a little bit of
a gray area at the moment so obviously
once we work out that we'll be able to
support full training schedules together
for the team as well and just go back to
basics
yeah with and you've got the delivery
guys the sales guys just to keep them
motivated and learning yeah and give
them a few ideas on you know just make
sure that the work skills using video
yeah I'm just putting so I've popped
them together something so they can
think well when I was in recruitment and
I was in my office all the things I
never had the time today
what kind of go and do now to make
myself better yeah and followed our
Lister's as long as there are if things
that they wanted to do that they don't
so my advice to anyone
later on feel it would just be get that
so I got a big house in our to really so
you come back to where can you doubt
those issues yeah nice and it could even
just be basic things like you know
getting on you you master templates
organized but research you client's
properly you know actually you know what
a client lists together if actually go
on websites and understand what they
doing you know really get to grips with
everything and see a couple of people
just obviously a question in there or
also just message very Connie Louise
you'll check it but yeah but less and
yes you can train more brightness and
HMRC confirms that you can train but I
think I think that is the thing that a
lot of conversations I've had is that
with the fact that you can even go into
the pool right now apply for the grant
or whatever like
we do this by the book that like you
don't have to be a banana gray area
because if it then means that you're not
eligible for the grant or whatever you
can okay that's in yeah I think I said
to my girlfriend who was followed from
today what what's on your what's on the
list when you said when you was used to
say I wish I had more time it's it's a
good question to ask yourself and what
what appears on that list and start
tackling those things on that there
Shawn anything to add mate like anything
that I think I think connection and self
development like a key really yeah as
Louise and John have both alluded to you
know it is still very much you know part
of the business and making sure they
feel like the part of the business and
can contribute in which you know
whichever way to the culture of the
business yeah I think from a
communication point of view for my
people it's very much led by them there
is some people in the feel that they
want a bit more of a daily checking call
or weekly checking call just to see what
to see how they're getting on whereas
some people are very much more or less
like I'll call you if I need you know if
I need anything if you know for need to
talk to you about anything so I think
you know letting them lead the
communication and how they want to be
kept involved as much as possible and
then and then I think on Louise's point
really just encouraging them to set
themselves up as as best as possible for
success when the inevitable market
upturn does come you know what what can
they be doing in their in their own
spare time to keep their skills up to
date yeah so that they positioning
themselves in the best possible way cool
um okay cool let let let segue into and
what you're hearing from your console
and this all obviously what what you're
experiencing yourself in terms of the
actual market right now so is it fair to
make the assumption that across the
board with you guys and your team's may
may be varied there there are some
opportunities but the majority of stuff
has been put on hold and yeah there's
not much going on in your so Louise you
you're your market is engineering
engineering yeah so unfortunately a lot
well
that we've called this week all the key
clients and companies we've placed with
and I mean they're not recruiting or
starting some on hold okay and so it's
it's not it's not really bad for it's
not great for this month
you know this particular time right now
as with as much well in the world I
think you know we've not even hit the
peak of the virus at the moment there's
a lot to consider when you're calling
around to these companies you know
people are gonna start being affected
personally by with family members
contracting the virus and knowing people
I know people I've got it yeah I think
you need to be like modeling needs so I
really think about how you do position
yourself if you are canvassing and you
ask them to come to notice because it
could be quite saying for some people
can't not do you business any good so
growing up these gonna be it's going to
be a fine line and it's just probably
managing that if you've got stuff
calling about still okay yeah and then
Sean and John then your markets like
yeah there's a lot of it it's all dried
up things and I was it quite similar
yeah I think change is changing daily I
think he's yeah I know it's fair to say
you asked me this question two weeks ago
we were on for this month so but I think
keeps changing daily I think you know
what why it's probably quite unique to
other recessions I've been through
before is your balance in the
uncertainty in the economy with the
obvious you know logistics of not over
everyone working from home and you know
not being able to on board new starters
or interview new starters even if they
wanted to so and I think again probably
different from other recessions I've
I've kind of been involved in is it's
pretty much every sector yeah across the
world that's impacted whereas it hadn't
always been that way so I think there is
still pockets of people recruit in there
is still opportunities the thing those
particularly in tech I would say those
those companies that were already set
off to so for people to work remotely
yeah maybe I have a product that they
want to deliver I've got funding already
for that product and I've got a
timescale that they they still need to
hear
we're finding that those guys are still
pushing on with recruitment and you know
trying to use it as an opportunity to
maybe Hoover up Talent
the the you know all the businesses car
at this moment but I think that the
general consensus is kind of caution
around certainly the next few weeks
okay so Louise was just touching on that
a bit there but I think that this was
really common from the last one
James Johnson's question what what is
the approach right now to develop
business which as we all just saying it
is difficult and there's a lot of stuff
that's going on hold Louise's talking
about being empathetic being a human
about it in understanding that the
people you are calling could be impacted
by this personally right so like yeah
what do you think with this then John
Rochon like how how can consultants
right now approach business development
and how should they be approaching that
you think what you tell in your guy's
conversations we've been having is we've
seen our job book drop from somewhere in
the reads of 250 live vacancies to circa
61 two weeks yeah now that could well be
we in some respects maybe had too many
vacancies so the upside there is you
know we've got less and we've got enough
people to concentrate fully on them to
get them filled so our philosophy is
let's fill the jobs we've got most of
them yeah and let's be more efficient
and more quality conscious than we've
ever been and let you know if we're used
to having maybe one person work on a
vacancy why not double down and have to
yeah why don't have three and ensure
that we've got the best chance possible
of filling back that gig and our
philosophy is you know let's kind of
let's deal with what we've got while
we've still got it yeah and in some
respects wait for the market to return
to us so you know we're not looking at a
hard sell we're not out there specking
candidates into companies like yeah
we're basically we're communicating with
our clients and we're saying look if you
are in a position to take on a tech
sales or marketing person in april/may
like what store now yeah isn't that you
need
space and you need some time you know
that's let's park it and let's talk to
you when you are in that position so I
think it's it's honing in and being more
efficient with the stuff you've got yeah
I've been trying to push you know push
water uphill okay that's interesting so
I guess so yeah like to tie this in
Stephanie Levinson's question on what
for anyone that isn't for what the next
steps and sounds like what should they
be focusing on then so what you're
saying is if you've got if your jobs
have dramatically decreased focus on
mostly the stuff that you do how much
make sense but don't see that's for some
people that are the people I spoke to
that could leach it could literally
whittle down to one John yeah two
clients right so I guess what you're
talking about there John and these are
some of the conversations I've had so
hopefully this helps is that ultimately
what's probably changed is the
expectations of that BD call or the
expectations of that sales call as in
instead of thinking about I want to try
and get a job out of this core which
would make it successful is let's have a
conversation about what your plans over
the next couple of months or starts a
build relationship which is a slightly
different expectation that it may have
been to the cool a couple of weeks ago
when you said did you pull that job on
our to go I'm in I can see where you're
coming from so I think the key thing is
the you know the appetite to take you
know you got any vacancies that's not
out there yeah finding out where they're
at and what they're doing and then
thinking about what help you can give
them so for example you know we're
looking to help our clients who are
hiring with their onboarding strategy
yeah
Ariel fruits are them that they can use
to help onboard the individual you know
we're helping them you know if they need
any help and assistance in terms of you
know what the markets going to look like
in three to six months and if we find
anything out in terms of what's going on
in their space we will look to
communicate that with them that me I
have an impact on their buying decisions
in months to come so I think the key
thing is whatever a client wants to do
you can't kind of blame them for doing
it yeah and it
if you know if the client you know cooks
headcount on 40 even if the client were
like renée's on an offer that's already
been made which you know we've all had
that that is the new life that were
living within so I think the key thing
for me is even if you've only got one
job then you should give yourself a very
very good chance of filling that job
yeah most consultants depending on the
markets don't place much more than one
or two people or people a month yes and
so you know if you feel what you've got
so if we if we've got 50 to 60 vacancies
and we fill all of them over the next
season we'd be doing just fine slowly I
think think about quality and thinking
about that added value and think about
those five-minute conversations you have
with candidates that can now be half an
hour so they're up skilled as much as
possible to go in and and get that job
and yes so they're running around
chasing your tail on five rolls and
doing a little bit on each of them
pretty badly do a fantastic you know
awesome job on one roll yeah I might
will remember you at the other side of
his and just one point I want to just
highlight there and show him we spoke
about this so I'd love to get your
thoughts on this and so one of the
questions that I got that was submitted
for this was and from a lady called
Charlotte and Lita
apology for pronounce that wrong
basically she said we are fortunate to
recruit within digital so some of our
clients are still hiring but are
hesitant unsure on how to onboard new
starters remotely right and this is a
really common headache that I've heard
from a lot of people so her question is
how are you managing this if they if
they are at all and do you have any tips
or advice that you can share because I
think that's what you just touched on
John but I know we spoke about is Shawn
what what comes up for you on that with
that yeah I think I think firstly it can
all be done digitally and I think the
more that you can lay out a process I
think look what it is with humans are
creatures of habit I think ultimately
and you know if you've always on-boarded
someone in one way then you know you
naturally fall back to that way of
onboarding barking is
education piece of clients if you can
educate them look you can what are your
objectives with onboarding someone and
what I found is it's moved it's moved
away
more or from like the policies and
procedures side of embodied someone
because that's almost come less
important I would argue in this current
climate so just focus on they're more
about integrating people within the
business ops killing them and getting
them as quickly as possible immersed
into your culture important to what
you're doing so a lot of that side of
onboarding can be done via video you
know we're encouraging we've got some of
our clients who hiring managers are
doing an introduction video for
themselves to to kind of enjoy the team
you know there's obviously team meetings
that can be done over zoom yeah you know
this a lot of content or video or
whatever that could be sense of people
to learn and so I think that the people
who are doing it best in my mind are
they're not focusing so much on you know
the policies and procedures and you know
have they kind of read the staff
handbook about X Y and Zed but the more
thinking about right okay well how can
we kind of upskill them as quickly as
possible
yeah in the role that we need do in and
can that be done virtually and and then
come how can we get them kind of
immersed in our culture and more into
what we are as a business as quickly as
possible
nice John anything to add to that that
you've been speaking to your clients
about what we've noticed is even they're
kind of the slowdown in the market we've
seen less of a slowdown in the states
than the UK okay
and what I'm seeing is that certainly
the guys in the states that they used to
onboarding people remotely I think
because the countries so so huge that's
the only option on occasion so yeah
beige they've just kind of cracked on
and you know people have been offering
people jobs last week and you know they
started this week so I think the the key
thing is you know we need to be thinking
about what we're doing with our business
now and I'm sure the guys thing in the
same you know do we need that
- we conduction in Manchester and
sending people up from London and or can
we actually get a you know some stuff in
the can from a training perspective and
the intros and the processes and the
procedures so I think most companies
will be looking at this and thinking
right
during this slower time what can we
build now that can save us money in the
quarters to come from an onboarding
perspective so I think whether it's you
know you know being able to onboard
remotely or whether you know we can do
meetings remotely and save money and
time kind of moving around the place you
know I think that's going to be a big
question for everybody moving forward
okay interesting
we're actually taking somebody on next
week okay yeah so and for me I feel like
it's a good thing we're gonna
communicate this to clients what we were
actually going to be doing but no the
time when you start a new job you don't
get given a lot of time you got thrown
in the deep end you got expectancy to do
you know 100 hundred miles an hour where
is speak to the clients about just
taking it really slowly and just making
sure that become today actually
understands the business and yeah in
full because you're you know every
business is guilty if I'm writing
someone and then you know to beasley
like you've always been here yeah so
what the way we're gonna do it is to set
like bite-sized chunks for the new
starter and then just look feeding back
to them and just keep checking in on it
on this and what did they get from it
and they've got a real good chance to
learn about your business properly and
you know reading documents properly and
learning about the products or services
and so I think it's it's a good thing in
a way these recipes whether you can
gather across the plates are not I think
you would need to have you know good to
half and I were quite five-minute
conversations on a regular basis yeah
educate them on that okay that's pretty
interesting so what what I just really
love to expand on and this is pretty
much Rob's question but the whole
question that I'm just going to read
word for word was from a chap called
Darren Simmons and it's it's sort of all
linked with this so his question is has
anyone had success diversifying their
offering in too broad a consultancy
right so talking about here could you
impact the onboarding process could that
be something you monetize or just add
value around Rob's question around
looking at different revenue streams
right now right so Darren's question is
yeah so ie
benchmarking competitor analysis talent
pooling etc so then have you guys and
you guys thought about this or I don't
know thought about some of the different
things that you could potentially
monetize in this short to medium term
that isn't you hire this person than you
pay me a fee then if you'd looked at
that yeah one of the things I was
looking at prior to this whole crisis
actually so I was having conversations
with a couple of guys in Manchester and
Nick guy over in New York about I see
the the pricing of recruitment and
changing so it's it's changed in
everything else we do bar recruitment
okay so you know the way we pay for
Netflix or the way we paint the sky or
the way we pay LinkedIn you know that's
not on how much you use it and how much
success you have it's you know it's
subscription-based and quarterly basis
up I had talked to people about you know
instead of charging clients on you know
the win you know the higher the boom on
the see whether we should be looking to
kind of charge people on the in three
days their growth well charge them on a
subscription basis yeah on certain
metrics that you know we charge so much
a month than what you get for that month
yeah
X Y or Z based on how much you pay so I
think what will come out of this in
three six months time is
I think we'll be forced into looking at
the way we charge and the way we price
and the way people purchase kind of our
services from us so we've not really
thought so much about you know the
additional services while we've still
got Lyon vacancies the definite time but
if they run out you know it's kind of
leads to us you know what else can we
offer that our clients will value and
our clients will derive benefits from
okay Sean you've beautiful about this or
hard anyone yeah I think obviously the
challenge at the moment is you know a
lot of businesses are in probably a
price-sensitive know it's kind of a you
know a bit of a difficult conversation
to say right well for something else
over and above actually finding people
for your pop sure but I think you know
what what what we have been doing in
site is evolving our offering and
offering a lot more added value services
more based on commitment really than
necessarily charging extra for them and
I think if you you know if you can hold
those now then then potentially down the
line when there is more confidence and
it is probably less price sensitive us
suppose then then I think you would be
able to for them so some of the things
we've been doing is working with clients
on their EVP you know really as part of
our process helping them get get people
on board is looking at how the branding
themselves in the market what's their
what's their process for onboarding and
tying that into well we you know we can
help you get part of those attracting
the best staff to you is making sure
that in the market you're your brand is
representative in the right way so again
I think that is a thing that can be
could be charged for at a later date
yeah and I think you know you touched on
it kind of competitor analysis talent
pooling things like that we've all done
that more as a retained search process
is part of that they're necessarily a
standalone product but you know if
someone's confident enough to sell that
in the current climate then and can
charge them then fair play to them you
know obviously get them to get me
so not on this then I I've seen a lot of
it and I've definitely thought about it
so I'm coming to Dillon's question
basically talking about if an incline
has lowered their fees due to the
current crisis were in price sensitive
that you're talking about and a lot of
people I've seen online that offered
their services for free and things like
that like what do we think about that
should should you be offering your
services for free right now like I don't
know what what do we think about that
cuz I think a lot of people are thinking
them and doing that so what do we think
about that I don't think you should be
off for you you're up you should you
know you should be offering your cat and
of course service of placing candidates
or whatever the recruitment side would
be free ultimately but I do think that
more and more there is an opportunity to
give value and give content and give
information for free yeah will that will
in return kind of win your business
further down the line so my personal
point of view would be don't often your
core services for free and if businesses
are asking you to do that then they
probably don't value what you offer but
you can offer you know additional things
around your core service as a value add
on the understanding that you're
building relationships with customers
that hopefully are then gonna pay you
for the core services you offer mmm the
worldA clients that are going to use
this to achieve in it for those those
discounts as well I think you have to
look at it on a case-by-case basis I
think of discounts a little bit
different it's obviously free so
discount mainly or if they was asking
for free I don't know how they're
expected to run so like say they're not
they're not gonna value you long term so
maybe you look at your client base if
you've starting to get that yeah if you
have you a lot of any of you guys had
conversations around just grown up
conversations around look we're both in
a difficult situation right here you you
haven't invoice it you need to pay or
this is what of course we can look at
spreading it or whatever Jan I mean I
think that it seems like a lot of people
having those conversations yeah I think
again everyone is in a similar situation
that you know cash flow and and things
like that are important so you know if
companies are genuinely in a situation
where they need more time to pay or
whatever then those are things you could
definitely look at but I would always
personally try and advise on right okay
well how can you tie them into some some
longer-term commitment so you know for
example if if someone is saying about
well I need a discount on a particular
there's a placement that's already been
done and already agreed then you know
tie it tie it back to say okay well you
know we'll we'll credit this again you
know we'll credit this against the
future placement or you know let's let's
look at a piece of work over the next
six months yeah and which is going to
cost X and if we hit that piece of work
of then we will discount you further but
I think I think for me would it would
really be making sure you've got the
commitment at the other end rather than
just people using this is an opportunity
just to get out a payin off yeah I'll
get hey you know my own prices yes
something I think is a bit of a weird
time it does feel bit with chasing
voices and like we have this one the
last one and there's someone else not
chasing debt Ryan it's can be difficult
just made sure again that the
conversations were being done in the
right way and you have the clients
understood where I'm coming from a lot
of it with contracts and contracts are
payments anyway so it's not too
difficult when you can say well Cal paid
the contractor yeah it's it's not that
hard to say and but you know there are
ways around it and you don't have to go
in all guns blazing I think it's you
know if you do it in the right way and
the right
as well it might be that you need to
change who cup he makes the car if
you've not got someone you might have a
really good credit control or maybe the
ability that game money game but that
might not be the right person right now
to do this so you just search it even if
you switch it to yourself and so you can
control the bit so a question I want to
go to claim you're having this question
and this this will come for a couple of
times because I think it's fair to say
the other question I'm just looking at
prepared on my phone from Rory from be
recruitment and it's very much like if
your market right now is just in the
complete shutdown and you've got your
niche that's what you've been operating
them have the last however long and like
she'd like if if you're in a place where
right now everything is shut down and
then you can't send the opportunity you
should you should you be diversifying
right now or should you stitch your guns
and stay niche what do we think about
that I think like my thoughts on that
are is depends it depends on the niche
you're in yeah you know a niche that you
potentially considering cuz what we've
got to look at is if you're jumping into
somebody else's niche yeah if the
companies already in that niche a
furloughing staff because it's so tough
and they've got 10 12 15 years of
experience doing it that's been tough
it's gonna be tough so I you know I
wouldn't dream of jumping into shawls
market and be trying to compete with him
and his business yeah did what he does
and I think you know he might think the
same jumping into sales
you know we Finley James so I think in
that situation I think control the
controllables
and that's where you do take advantage
of the furlough and and basically get
your cost base down to as low as you can
yeah because you could crack on and do
more money in trying to attack a market
place that you've got no experience of
and no exposure to yeah and that could
cut your runway in half as opposed to
sticking with your niche you know
learning development getting all that
good stuff done by and buying yourself
time which is that
that's where I've seen the furloughs
yeah buying some time for the business
and extending your own way to stick with
what you know
yeah education recruiters jumping into
engineering recruitment or vice versa I
I think that's potentially the way to
the poorhouse so it's not a route I'd go
down but yeah that makes a we we went
into panic mode a little bit when it
when you first oil started off and we
stayed and not going into different
markets but ones that were sort of maybe
next to next to us and so obviously in
engineering we could start in it like
the PP companies textile companies it
isn't what we do it's quite easy for us
to do it but it wasn't what we do and I
realized like after 1012 days trying to
do that he's going to be agencies that
I've already got it covered
so why we're not gonna just what John
just said why are you gonna be any
better about this and so I think the
quicker you realize just stick to what
you know learn more about what you know
forward if you can take the option to do
the fellow as well and buy yourself a
bit of time to to really niche down even
further than I would say in the markets
on your idea yeah and I say EE no clump
on markets when you have got a job on
putting a couple of people on it yeah ok
that's the point I was gonna make I
think there is you know there's an
opportunity for like a niche within a
niche so you know if you are for example
in engineering is there certain sectors
of engineering that's still in your
vertical but are less affected you know
I don't know for example the utilities
industry because you've clearly got to
keep keep the lights on for example you
know then then I think there is the
opportunity to look at sectors that you
there may be a little bit more resilient
you know that you know books still
sticking within your niche okay but I
wouldn't I would advise completely
change in niche unless of course you
know that niche was already you know was
already challenging coming into this
situation then you know suppose you
could look at it and say right well you
know particularly if I'm safer load for
example is there an opportunity for me
to to take that two months to map out
that new and we've got something new but
if you're only doing it because of this
particular situation and you're
confident there will be an upturn then I
would say ride it out and position
yourself in the best possible place to
take advantage when it does cool so
talking about riding out giving yourself
more runway these types of things Mark's
question I don't know that Shaun which
one that is before like or review on a
day-to-day basis and things change but I
think people just think wanting to know
what other people think and how they're
approaching it like yeah like mark
Marcus said there what what length of
time you can't be planning a full
casting I've run let let's just share
that with everyone how you we were
talking about it by kicking off we're
currently forecasting it on a quarterly
basis so we've got a plan for the next
three months but you know I think the
term John used was a cobra me is twice a
day with no fire lights it you know it
is staying on top of it daily very much
just because things are changing I think
the the variable that is also difficult
to forecast this you know we don't know
how long we're going to be in a lockdown
situation so you know if we knew that
okay definitely be out in two weeks time
then I think you could probably predict
when the up term would be a little bit
more confidently than you know at the
moment with you've got a forecast for
that worst-case scenario as well really
yeah okay is that the same for you guys
John and Louise yeah and I said earlier
on the cars to Shawn and Johnny T now so
yeah I've spent so much time planning
and then the next day I'd open my emails
I look on the news and then something
different happens or you find out
from the government because totally
throw sometimes in a good way or
sometimes in a bad way so I would say my
advice would be supply yeah weekly
monthly quarterly I would personally be
planning out or Christmas but and don't
stress too much if you've got to change
it on a daily basis because we probably
by nature of our planets and we want to
you know see this outcome but don't let
it stress you out if you have to change
it a little Christmas okay just a quick
one on this which i think is an
interesting point and probably really
valuable is sort of the things that your
look like so having a visibility in your
business right especially if your team
being remotely in terms of and I don't
know tools like cube 19 or whatever
right so how important is it to have so
what you're saying is you're planning
but what are the what are the things are
you making sure that you're checking on
a weekly basis or looking at the things
you have visibility on that sort of key
things that you're keeping the look on
to that's going to help form the
decisions that you make do you not I
mean is it just money in the business or
revenue like what what are the things
that you keeping a close eye on I have
interests in terms of data points or
anything like that I think for me it's
what one is sticking close to you know
our financial manager and basically how
are things looking for the month ahead
and you know three months and six months
so you know we've got a plan to the next
three months and then four months
supporter six as well but I'm looking at
cube you know every two or three hours
okay things are changing and I think the
other thing I'm doing is I've talked
about this before but people talk about
you know what what things look like a
week ago and two weeks ago so you know I
I had people telling me well I've got 25
rolls but 20 of them are on hold and
it's like no you've got five rolls
but that's been quite kind of
destructive people now know where the
Ronnie it's taken some people longer
than others to realize that a job and a
vacancy that you had on three weeks ago
doesn't exist anymore so yeah you know
basically looking at the the new world
and it's a bit like you know for me
April 1 it's like starting a new
business so we're good q1 great q2
a great March but we're now a completely
different company come April 1 and we're
basically back to where we were 10 years
ago in terms of you know how many people
are working on the business and the kind
of vacancies we're dealing with so we
need to lean on that experience of
growing something and dealing with you
know less volume and higher quality
which is what we did back then so I
think keeping a handle on the money and
the cash and the bank and the pipeline
and the debt chasing and all that cool
stuff yeah is important and then the
next thing is the villain visibility via
cube or mellitus you know any business
intelligence to basically say look this
is where I'm at at you know 3 o'clock
this is the real number it's not where
I'd like to be 2 weeks ago yeah just
kind of being comfortable with the
present yeah allows you to be more
positive about the future of me cool
yeah and she said just a complete change
of subject hey guys but I wanted to make
sure you recover it and being a parent
difficult in itself but a lot of people
I've spoken to you and being a parent at
home and having kids running lead whilst
you're trying to work from home what's
that been like for you guys has really
helped because I'd like to think there's
quite a few people tuning in right now
that do you have kids I mean I've heard
people taking turns to run school
lessons in their kitchen during PE
lessons in the garden doing different
shifts like what was Shawn Louise what
have you
I think just I think just like the kids
I think if you go bust like when you
were younger you used to play out on the
street all time you was allowed to do
all these cool things in the garden like
make downs climb over the fence get more
D you know do all this stuff and I just
think if you've got the space let them
just be kids and it'll make your life a
bit easier I don't think so much
structure is that necessary I just think
they set up here then everyone's happier
and the stealing is not going to go to
change that much if you're not doing you
know six hours a day okay
I would do worry too much about about
that yeah I mean you know I've got three
kids aging from yeah coming up to two to
seven is my oldest so thankfully of my
wife's been amazing in terms of support
but and actually in a weird kind of way
you know getting time to have breakfast
with them and doing doing more quality
time but still working similar hours
because I'm not traveling to and from
work and yeah various of the things like
that of you know I've had to take more
of an interest in math sort of Charlie
plays football so we run on great times
I would break in the morning a break in
the afternoon which you have 20 minutes
in football but I think just on a kind
of a put in work a side point of view
you know we're obviously going through
the world's going through a very
difficult time and I think trying not to
be our stress they're not so worried and
shield in the kids from that because you
know last thing I think they pick up on
that that type of stress and worry
and last thing anyone needs at the
moment is he's more of that so that's
been something we've been really
conscious to do is is try and keep the
kids happy as we said just enjoying
themselves and hopefully not aware of
what's going on in the wider world so
much yeah a bit different in that we've
got 20 year old twins so we've had
Joseph come back from Sheffield uni
Aaron's come back from Leeds uni but
we're eating better than we ever have in
that week yeah the kids are making or
three meals a day and I can go out to my
fridge now the menus up for the week so
as we sort of come come towards the end
here and just use it as a bit of a time
to sort of reflect really like what
would you over the so a question from
alien round which was over the last few
weeks what's been the biggest lesson
that you guys have learnt you think I
think just on a personal level I think
it's reinforced how important time is
you know I think previously on a
personal level probably didn't feel like
I had enough time in the day and now
weirdly enough you've got loads of time
in the day per se yeah because you can
doing a lot of other things but you're
not able to use that time with the same
quality that you would want to use it
you know that in other things so
learning for me really both in my
business and in my personal life is is
you know look don't take time for
granted and use it constructively yeah
Louise John biggest learning last couple
of weeks thanks for me and it's a little
bit yeah grounded me a bit more than the
No Mas you know just being nearly
thankful fair like basic things in life
fairly yeah but we're doing quite a bit
of charity work in a minute
money for food banks and we've been
going over to those places and to see
you know this state that people have
been at the moment that can't get food
it it's just some even going to be
allies health divided today we have any
way to know especially where clearly
cream and you from afar tonight I eat
you in a job where you can control the
control your earnings to a next and so I
think just just made me really thankful
for being in that position yeah
John it's learning yeah I think for me
it's I think controlling the
controllables so yeah you know not
getting too carried away if something
happens that's really really good or I'm
not getting sued down yeah if anything
that happened as that is horrific so
just being in a position where by my
philosophy you know every evening myself
and sorrow go out for a walk and we are
philosophies right we're one day closer
to the inside most yeah and you know the
world's going to be a different place
you know we're going to be you know in
such a different kind of family yeah but
just being appreciative of the fact that
at the moment you know we're all healthy
yeah you know we're all strong and you
know we're very fortunate to be in a
position where you know we're dealing
with this because there's many people
who would swap with us tomorrow yeah so
you know being you know controlling what
you can control and don't sweat it if
things aren't going right and being
there for your people and you know
having everybody kind of you know
ringing you up in recent weeks and I
mean one of the most remarkable things
for me has been you know people ringing
me up so now how are you yeah nobody's
door 9 10 years and how so on that note
as you tend them one day closer to
getting on the other side of this like
how were your guys force on how the
recruitment industry or just how are
things going to look at the other side
of this do you think how different are
they going to be I I think the I think
the the work from home situation I think
will mean
there's probably more flexibility I
think nope even my own personal point of
yo I was a bit old school on that front
always kind of wanting to be in the
office but I think there is something to
be said that you can be productive to a
certain extent working from home so I
think you'll see more recruitment
businesses kind of having a blended
approach of people working from home and
not I think I think you know hopefully
from a customer point of view I think it
will continue the steer from you know
what are kind of purely transactional
relationships of just someone trying to
sell that one candidate or trying to get
that one job on to to build in longer
term relationships with people because
you know they will have had things to
talk to them about when they haven't had
that job on or when they haven't had
that one candidate so hopefully and
certainly the way we're position in our
business is to try and have stronger
relationships both with candidates and
clients when when we come out the other
side of this mmm
nice yeah I think that work from home
pieces and we really interest in after
all of this
yeah and Louise John how do you see
things look in I think video is going to
be honestly the big one in today yeah I
think the big change and from our point
of view engineering companies and don't
really use videos that much so we always
have to go over and drive to the site
which is brilliant Ross but I think
those quick online meeting I think
that's gonna improve mindsets on that as
well and honestly the claims are gonna
have to get on board they'll just become
a bit more normals yeah and I think
video and pushing each pushing people
our comfort zone a lot up on that isn't
it already happened so that would be a
really big positive mmm in all effects
definitely John anything that you're
thinking about I think for me where I
see it changing is I think what you'll
find is the good guys who looked after
their clients candidates staff
relationships I think they'll come out
of this in there
six nine miles time in a really really
strong position yeah I think the the bad
guys won't come out of it
I think they'll go bust yeah which
unfortunately does then create an
opportunity for the good guys so I think
there'll be a bit of a reckoning and you
know how you treat your suppliers and
Kaniksu clients and how our suppliers
trio's yeah
know me remember it'll be remembered and
they'll be a reckoning I think I see you
know a lot of people doing some great
stuff and helping people where they can
and you know I think there's going to be
an amazing opportunity for the companies
who've done that and recognize that
during these tough times yeah and
finally final question guys so it was
from Sandra Patel things of great
questions are closed on I think fair to
say a lot of people feel like they're in
a survival mode right now I think that
would sure and when we spoke a last
couple days that's how you answered the
phone yeah I'm surviving
like what watch what's your number one
sort of survival bit of advice for
people listening right now what sure
your number one survival bit of advice I
think just just look for opportunities
and celebrate any small win I think you
know when I'm speaking to my T's andmy
consultants you know the conversation is
not gone from okay well I've not got a
job I've not got an interview I've not
made a placement - okay well I progress
that relationship I've got this bit of
information from that client and still
some elaborate in that as as John stares
that so one step closer to something
that's going to yield something when
this when this up turn you know
inevitably comes so celebrate the small
wins I would say nice Louie's say that
say like I'm sorry gonna be off alright
what what's your one piece of like
survival bit of advice for people
survival
I think for me would be understanding
yourself and learning about what you
like as a person right now and I've been
beating my disc profile recently so if
you've not done that for their face you
actually do it and it sort of tells you
how you behave and in certain ways so in
my conflicts and yeah under stresses to
flat laughs I think when everybody at
last week it did actually help me go
I'll actually I'm not absolutely
psychopath I think he just helps you
stay a bit grounded and stay calm so
nice one decide when to send yourself
love that yeah my thoughts I think don't
lose your sense of humor I think it's
very easy in this situation watching the
news and seeing social media to kind of
go down that negative path and there's
enough of that out there yeah I think
keeping your sense of humor and keeping
you keeping a positive mindset and you
know but my kids are obviously a little
bit older but that they were taking the
mickey out me the other day saying I
remember that last week you owned a
really successful a break in the mickey
out yourself and kind of remaining
grounded and keeping a positive mount -
I think is crucial
yeah amazing may well look Sean John
Louie's absolute pleasure thank you
everyone before I shoot and then we
appreciate your time thanks for sharing
your four perspectives really appreciate
it so everyone keep hands and then real
well sent in eight seconds I need to
time that better next time